Philip the second leads Spain in sid
meier's civilization 6 he was king of
Spain at the apex of its golden age
Philip was a champion of the Catholic
faith and a patron of the arts and
culture Spain's special ability is
called treasure fleet their trade routes
between continents give extra yields
they can also combine ships and depletes
earlier than other sibs as defender of
the faith Phillip gets the special
ability el escorial not only do his
units get a combat bonus against players
following other religions but his
inquisitors can remove heresy one extra
time Spain also gets the conquistador
unique unit conquistadors get a
significant bonus when there is a
Spanish missionary Inquisitor or apostle
on their hex if a conquistador is
adjacent to a city when it is captured
it automatically converts to Spain's
majority religion
the mission is a unique improvement that
provides faith it gives bonus faith when
built on a different continent from the
capital and it gives science if built
next to a campus Spain's religious
strengths allow it to control other
religions and spread their own around
the world bonuses tied to different
continents will give you a strong
incentive to spread cities across the
globe or take them for your empire will
your prudence bring your enemies into
the fold how will you lead Spain in sid
meier's civilization six
you